[Music]
before we close tonight I want to
address the new very serious sexual
misconduct allegations against judge Roy
Moore if you watch this program
regularly you know I do not and will
never rush to judgment because we have
seen the media and politicians get it
wrong so many times I've outlined all of
that now in light of new information
about judge Roy Moore we have to address
this issue again tonight we should be
troubled by two things in this case when
the Washington Post story first broke I
said that the allegations should be
taken seriously they should be fully
investigated this is a serious a
fourteen-year-old girl we need to
discover the truth I also said I can
understand when women wait years to come
forward because of the evil that in
cases where they are guilt that men
argue it's evil trauma I can understand
people having a difficult time talking
about it even years later so this past
Friday I had judge Roy Moore on my radio
program and I methodically step-by-step
went through point by point every
allegation against him and let him
respond listen to part of that interview
The Washington Post alleges that back in
1979 when she was 14 years old
that she had sexual encounters with the
then 32 year old Roy Moore what do you
make of these allegations well Shawn
first let me say this these allegations
are completely false
false and misleading would it be unusual
for you as a 32 year old guy to have
dated a woman as young as 17 now be a 15
year difference or a girl 18 do you
remember dating girls that young at that
time not generally no you don't
specifically remember having any
girlfriend that was in her late teens
even at that time I don't remember that
and I don't remember ever dating any
girl without the permission of her
mother and I think in her statement she
said that her mother actually encouraged
her to go out with me now he gave a
third answer for me when he said well
not generally not without permission of
the mother
it's he'd been consistent and a lot of
other people saw it the same thing
it took three times on the third time he
unequivocally then denied that he'd ever
date dated somebody in their late teens
even though I was pressing again and
again now here yesterday we have another
accuser that came forward
she is alleging that Roy Moore sexually
assaulted her when she was 16 years old
and he was in his 30s
here is how judge Moore responded to
that accusation I want to address what's
been brought out in television today by
Gloria Allred in a client that she has
about things I allegedly did I want to
make it perfectly clear the people of
Alabama know me they know my character
they know what I've stood for in the
political world for over 40 years and I
can tell you without hesitation this is
absolutely false I never did what she
said I did I don't even know the woman I
don't know anything about her he denied
knowing this fifth accuser but this
accuser has now brought forth a yearbook
that Moore appeared to sign quote to a
sweeter more beautiful girl I could not
say Merry Christmas love Roy Moore DEA I
looked at the handwriting I know some
people on Twitter have said things about
this here's where I am tonight between
this interview that I did and the
inconsistent answers between him saying
I never knew this girl and then that
yearbook comes out for me the judge has
24 hours you must immediately and fully
come up with a satisfactory explanations
for your inconsistencies that I just
showed you must remove any doubt if you
can't do this then judge Moore needs to
get out of this race this country has
way too many issues and problems the
American people deserve a hundred
percent truth and honesty
we need correct answers the first time
on issues this serious judge Moore you
owe that to the people of Alabama the
Republican Party that you represent and
to the country which is suffering under
so many problems we deserve answers
consistent answers and truth thank you
for being with us